113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 21
can a species de-evolve
before i start in today i just want to
remind viewers that if you have a
question about evolution you can submit
it
on the stated clearly website
statedclearly.com
forward slash contact and over there
there's a contact form
i do have quite a few there that i've
already had
submitted to me and it's going to take
me a while to get through them but yeah
that's
that's where that's how you submit a
question so
today's question comes from jessica
and jessica writes john if evolution is
a thing
is devolution a thing can a species d
evolve for example could a population of
great apes evolve
back into small-bodied long-tailed
monkey-like animals
your friend jessica
it's actually kind of two questions one
one question is could apes
you know evolve into these long-tailed
small-bodied
uh creatures so maybe a population of
chimpanzees for example could
chimpanzees evolve tails and
become smaller over evolutionary time
the answer to that is yes that could
definitely happen
there's no reason why it couldn't that
would we call that devolution or
d evolution the answer to that is no
and the reason for that is kind of just
uh
because that's not what what we call it
i guess we could have called it that if
we wanted to
but a lot of science educators have
decided that calling it that
causes a lot of confusion and sort of
promotes a misconception about evolution
and that misconception is that
evolution is a progressive thing
it's goal oriented so that somehow
things want to evolve to be more complex
or more like modern organisms
uh we were somehow on a trajectory to
become
human for example as one of these uh
these misconceptions that
the concept of de-evolution or
devolution
ends up promoting i'm probably showing
my true colors a little bit too strongly
this week because i think this is the
third week in a row maybe just the
second week in a row that i've mentioned
star trek but
there's a really funny episode of star
trek where they talk about
d evolution so yeah it's it's season
seven episode 19 i think that's what i
wrote down on my notes
so there's a virus and it starts making
everybody's
turned off genes turn back on and they
start
turning into different types of
organisms from their evolutionary
history so here's counselor troy turning
into
like a frog type thing an amphibian
here's
uh commander riker turning into a
a hominin an early hominin and then
we've got
one of the guys transformed into a
spider for some reason
so oh yeah the best thing is that data's
cat
evolves into an iguana i guess the
people in the
makeup department got tired of doing
their jobs they're like uh
we'll just we'll just turn the cat into
an iguana pretty much every biology
teacher hates this episode of star trek
but i should actually do a whole episode
on it because there's actually some
kind of cool concepts that you can use
this episode for
things like atavisms and uh what is it
that a virus can do can viruses
activate latent genes or like turned off
genes
and what would happen if that did occur
so there's lots of cool things you can
talk about with this but yeah the
devolution the evolution is really
popular in science fiction
but it's sort of wrong-headed to think
this way it didn't really have to be
that way though i mean we
it could have been that scientists
decided to really hold on to the term
they could have used it as a word that
defines the loss of a complex trait
over evolutionary time that could have
been described as
de-evolution or the return to an
ancestral-like
phenotype that could have been described
as de-evolution so
what you would describe jessica as this
uh this evolution
of chimps or you know great apes into a
monkey-like phenotype that could have
been something that scientists
officially called devolution but it's
just
historically that's not what happened
historically people
got upset with the confusion that this
graphic causes
actually and other like older ideas
about
the superiority of humans to other
animals so there is this
really difficult thing in our culture
that biology teachers have to constantly
fight against
and that is this idea that there's a
march of progress that evolution is some
sort of a march of progress
and this graphic which is a very famous
graphic is
one of the things that accidentally
promoted this idea
this graphic suggests that there was
some sort of a destiny to become human
and that's not the case things just
evolve and things can evolve to become
more complex
or less complex it's just evolution this
is just how evolution works
and in the case of you know humans and
and chimps for example
well our chimp-like ancestor that we
evolved from
it's not necessarily that we're more
complex than that chimp-like ancestor
we're just
different than that ancestor it's kind
of hard to say
whether or not we're more complex or
less complex
so yeah scientists don't like to use the
word
devolve or de-evolution because it
promotes
this idea that evolution is is
progressive
and so you can actually go backwards in
evolution that's not something that
people like to promote so
we don't use these words instead the
loss of a complex trait over
evolutionary time
we call that a loss of function or a
loss of function mutation
and then they return to an
ancestral-like phenotype
there's different ways to describe that
one is is called
toxic atovism and
you could also just call it convergent
evolution so a group could
through convergent evolution rediscover
a phenotype so a body form
that's somewhat at least superficially
similar to the body form of one of its
ancestors
so yeah scientists have different words
to describe what you are describing
as devolution or d
and here's a really cool paper less is
more
natural loss of function mutation is a
strategy
for adaptation and it talks about this
is one way that
adaptation can occur one way to think
about
why a loss of a function can sometimes
actually be adaptive
it can help an organism better survive
and reproduce is just to think about
you know a soldier coming back from war
during a war your helmet and your gun
and your boots and all that stuff
those things are really useful but if
you're just trying to get a job
at a grocery store you know carrying
around a giant gun
is gonna be it's gonna make it hard for
you to get that job
so as environments change sometimes
really complex adaptations suddenly
become useless
and you actually benefit by losing them
so
loss of function mutations end up being
adaptive all the time
in evolution and there's a really really
cool
example of this actually in humans
so check this out this is a hela cell
and these cells come from
a woman named henrietta lacks she had
cervical cancer
and these cells were removed from that
tumor and
human cells are really hard to keep
alive in cell culture
but for reasons that i'm not going to go
into here her
tumor cells were really good at
surviving
in petri dishes and because of that
they started being sold as cells to do
experiments on
human cells that people can do
experiments on in the lab
it's unethical usually to do experiments
on living humans
so here we've got a bunch of cells human
cells and we can do experiments on those
cells
and learn a lot about human cell biology
from these cells and so these are
really popular cells that are used in
laboratories all over the world
there's a lot of controversy over this
because henrietta was not informed that
her cells were being sold
but here's a different type of imaging
where we can see the same cells
this is uh we're doing fluorescent
imaging which
the blue here is the nucleus and the
green are the filaments
all of these are hela cells
different types of imaging of the same
types
of hela cells and here we have another
electron microscope image this shows
us the three-dimensional structure of
the cells
this used to be one hela cell that just
recently split into
above it here i have the name helacyton
garth larry which is a proposed
species name for these cells
and the reason that some people say that
we should we should consider this these
hela cells to be
their own species is because they have
evolved so much in the laboratory that
they will actually infect petri dishes
where they were not supposed to be
and so they can actually spread and
reproduce
on their own inside of a unique
environment
i mean it's it's the environment of the
laboratory but
that is their specific niche
or niche that they have evolved to
survive inside of and so some people say
we need to consider this to be a brand
new species
of organism i i really like that idea i
think we should
consider this to be its own new species
this would be an example of
what scientists would call loss of
function evolution
but i think it's really cool i do not
like the name that they chose for it
first of all it ignores henrietta and it
also hides
the actual genus that it came from which
we are the genus homo
homo sapiens right so i think that we
should actually call it
homo henrietta if i were naming it i
would call it homo henrietta
but yes i do agree we should consider
this to be its own
unique species i think this is awesome
so there you go jessica is devolution a
thing
no it's not officially a thing it's not
the term that scientists use
but loss of function adaptations
are certainly a thing next question
you